so we are going to separately discuss
this bizarre outburst that donald trump
had on twitter over the weekend
but here i want to focus in specifically
on the absolutely
massive cyber attack believed to have
been perpetrated by russia
on the united states we've now learned
of a massive and
ongoing long-term cyber hack by russia
with evidence mounting more and more
that points to russia
now of course you can always say we can
never believe
anything we're told about who did it but
in that case you also couldn't believe
the things that trump says or what
anybody says so that's sort of a
non-starter argument if we want to
really evaluate this on on its merits
but the details as we know them right
now are that
five major federal agencies were
breached uh according to multiple
intelligence agencies it's abundantly
clear that it was russia that did it
now multiple intelligence agencies
drafted a statement saying
russia did this and the white house
blocked the release
of that statement according to a senior
administration official
donald trump's secretary of state mike
pompeo even appeared on right-wing radio
show
on the the right-wing radio show hosted
by mark levin
and said quote we can say pretty clearly
that it was the russians that engaged in
this activity
pompeo didn't get super specific but u.s
officials have said privately
it was the foreign intelligence service
the svr of russia
that's what sort of replaced the kgb
no one is suggesting china played a role
they believe it was russia it's not
hugely controversial
but donald trump goes on twitter and
contradicts
his own secretary of state pompeo as
well as all intelligence agencies
and says you know it could have been
china who did it something for which we
have
no evidence whatsoever donald trump
tweeting quote
the cyber hack is far greater in the
fake news
media than in actuality i have been
fully briefed and
everything is well under control russia
russia russia
is the priority chant when anything
happens because lame stream
is for mostly financial reasons
petrified
of discussing the possibility that it
may be china it may
no evidence of that remember there could
also have been a hit on our ridiculous
voting machines during the election
which is now obvious that i won big
that's not true
making it an even more corrupted
embarrassment for the usa
so that there are so many uh
elements to focus on here number one
obviously donald trump is not going to
hold russia accountable
in his last month left in office that's
completely clear but
he's also adding without evidence that
the hack
even including included more stuff
like voting machines during the election
so it's considered the stunning nature
of what he's saying
trump is distorting what has taken place
downplaying it and saying the fake news
is blowing it out of proportion
but then adding that there were actually
even more
things hacked than what the fake news
media is telling you
raising this idea that voting machines
were hacked which is completely
self-serving
merely to support his bogus voter fraud
theory so
at the same time he says this wasn't
really a big deal
but voting machines were also hacked
which nobody is mentioning which sort of
makes it sound like it's an even bigger
deal
than what is being reported because
nobody's reporting that voting machines
were hacked because there's no evidence
of it
and then at the same time sort of like
as the cherry on top
floating that it might be china when
nobody thinks it was china and there's
no evidence that it was china
now you don't have to be in favor of
attacking russia
neither as a left winger or a right
winger to merely acknowledge
there's really no reason to doubt that
russia did this and to concede
that there's no reason to think china
did do it because we don't have any
evidence that china did anything so
this is a few different things together
first this is
another example of trump opting out
of even a mild rebuke of russia that's
common we've seen that
this entire presidency second this is
donald trump
trying to make anything that is out
there in the news
to be evidence that the election was
stolen from him when he simply lost
plain and simple and then number three
this is trump again trying to criticize
china
even when they've not actually done the
thing he's talking about
and fourth of course it's donald trump
focusing
on entirely the wrong things as usual
the response should be number one
how do we deal with this thing that
russia did
and number two as the president he
should be talking about the fact that
more than 3
000 people are now dying every day from
coronavirus
and he's not come out and talked about
it he seems done with coronavirus
and number three trump still hasn't
conceded and that's globally shameful as
well so trump
silent on how to deal with russia silent
on 3000 coronavirus deaths today
silent on conceding this election but
very loudly suggesting maybe china
actually did this hack
it's pathetic it's dangerous
it's a national security threat and it
is now an emergency to get this guy out
and that's coming we are 30 days away
30 days away from donald trump being
gone
and that's something that's not just
good for the country that's very good
for the world
hey take a minute to check out our
sponsor it's called
just egg many of you know that over the
years i've made my diet
more plant-based for a variety of
reasons i've always loved eggs
and just egg is a great way to take a
food many of us love
but make it a plant-based version just
egg has all the protein of
eggs but it's made from mung beans so it
uses 98 percent less water
and causes 93 fewer carbon emissions
than a conventional egg
just egg cooks and tastes exactly like a
conventional egg i've tried it for
omelettes scrambled eggs french toast
banana bread
pad thai even anything you'd normally
use eggs for
i actually think if i cooked something
for a friend without telling them
about just egg they wouldn't even know
the difference
you can find it in the egg aisle at your
grocery store
or on amazon prime now or instacart they
also have a frozen version which is
perfect for breakfast
sandwiches just egg check it out